we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p now this is a
voicemail it's very very nice it's a
it's a sort of a mess a positive message
in light of the election but it's also
really funny i think unintentionally
take a listen to hide david we could
kill less for the again aren't and then
don't think we don't think you are but
you are extremely brilliant and a lot of
those rednecks that you get those
patriot meals from all right ignorant
stupid and they're rednecks okay you
know and keep going on David you're
really helping me yes and we have 14 in
college another door that's going to be
going to college another year or so we
have two younger children when that the
stay up to on the young one stay up to
watch your program in their learning a
lot from thank you and we thank you very
much god bless you david and keep on
truckin sweetie i think what a voicemail
Pat what a voicemail a few notes number
one could care less shows up again
couldn't care less was what she meant
but it was very very sweet message no
matter what I like that whether i'm gay
or not she still likes the show that's
cool i mean that's nice right is a
fantastic voicemail but she seems like
you're actually distraught over what the
hey treats are saying about you you
think it really fazes you that much no
and I she became it sounded like a
little bit emotional there and I really
appreciate that but I'm okay with the
hatred males it's okay and also to the
untrained ear that might sound like a
Boston accent that is a Rhode Island
accent I don't know if it's called
Providence accent or Rhode Island accent
but there's parts of Providence that
have us a Boston ish accent and it is a
little different Pat see I'm so used to
hearing it around here that I didn't
notice that she had a dialect in any any
uh state you didn't you didn't recognize
recognize it now wow now that see I
believe that our audience that is not
from this area they would hear that and
they would immediately say that is a
very noticeable accent but because you
grew up here you don't even hear it
doesn't even phase me know amazing
amazing what we've learned today uh all
right on the bonus show today anti-trump
protests rage we will talk about that we
will talk about rumors that President
Obama
we'll be pushing for the trans-pacific
partnership before leaving office and
what are you doing to take care of
yourself after this abortive election
all of those stories and more on the
bonus show sign up and get instant
access why wait it's instant access at
david pakman.com slash membership